alors avant de vous donner l'occasion de
poser des questions à ce génie dit il il
faudrait pour les téléspectateurs dire
ce qu'il y a dans ce lit de ce nouveau
livre le chêne et le veau de soja
glycine et il semble que c'est pierre
daix qui est mieux qualifié pour nous
dire ouf faire une sorte de panorama d'
d'abord c'est un très gros livre très
important et si l'on dit que c'est une
auto biographie de l'écrivain
soljenitsyne je crois qu'on reste tout
de même loin du compte
il faut tout de suite ajouté que c'est
un livre qui a été écrit dans un secret
aussi absolue que l'archipel du goulag
parce que soljenitsyne le considérer et
à mon avis à juste titre aussi explosif
alors sa demande tout de suite des
explications
et là je crois qu'il faut brièvement
débordé même le contenu du livre
remonter un peu dans la biographie de
soljenitsyne dire que quand la guerre
éclate entre l'allemagne et la russie
en 1941 il n'a pas encore 23 ans que
c'est un étudiant mais déjà scientifique
il est mobilisé dans le train des
équipages
c'est sur sa demande et parce qu'il le
veut qu'il entre dans une école
d'artillerie qu'il devient un officier
il conduit son unité jusqu'en suisse
orientale avec un courage qui est
reconnu et c'est là qu'un jour du début
de 1945 il est arrêté parce que il avait
une correspondance privée avec un de ses
amis dans laquelle il disait ce qu'il
pensait
gouvernement j'insiste là dessus parce
que plus tard quand il écrira l'archipel
du goulag et qu'il parlera des vlasov
ces prisonniers de guerre soviétiques
c'est une guerre qui sont tombées entre
les mains des allemands et qui ont
accepté de porter l'uniforme allemand
les polémiques contre lui oublieront que
lorsqu'il parle des blast off c'est un
combattant du fonds s'est parlé il est
donc arrêté au début de 1945 et là s'il
est brusquement jeter dans l'envers du
monde qu'il connaissait l'envers des
prisons puis les camps le goulag il
restera huit ans puisqu'il ne sera
libéré qu'au début de 1953
et c'est dans cet enfer des camps de
concentration qu'il devient l'écrivain
nous connaissons il devient cet écrivain
dans un lieu où écrire est impossible
est interdite il va donc être obligés
d'apprendre par coeur ses premières
oeuvres d'avoir recours aux problèmes de
dresser sa mémoire pour apprendre de la
prose et quand il sort de ce camp en 53
ils ne sont pas du tout comme par
exemple nous les anciens déportés des
camps hitlérien sommes sortis avec un
peuple pour nous accueillir et nous
demander ce que nous avions connu lui il
sort comme sortirait chez nous à
malfaiteurs interdit de séjour il doit
résider dans le sud du kazakhstan et sa
liberté surveillée ne cessera quand juin
1956 et c'est là la première phase est
au cours de ces années là qu'il va
devenir un écrivain qui écrit un
écrivain qui a des manuscrits mais il va
être obligé d'écrire dans une
clandestinité
peut-être encore plus absolu que celle
qu'ont connu nos écrivains de la
résistance puisqu'il est obligé de
dissimuler ses manuscrits de les
disséminer parce que simplement comme
ancien déporté il est exposé à une
perquisition banal de la police et qu'il
faut pas que l'on sache qu'il écrit
parce que il se trouve planteurs de
terribles secrets qui sont les secrets
du goulag et là il faut nouveau ouvrir
une parenthèse parce que il ya une
opinion reçu chez nous qui veut que
le goulag était révélée par les congrès
du parti soviétique qui sont occupés de
la déstalinisation or c'est faux
ce congrès la ont révélé des crimes
personnel de staline ou de quelques
autres dirigeants mais le goulag c'est à
dire le système concentrationnaire qui
avait duré 30 ans qui avait englouti des
millions d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
qui avait requis l'emploi de milliers de
gardes chiourmes le policier le
tortionnaire
ce système là qui appartenait aux
institutions et au régime est resté
jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore à secret
absolu seul seul jénine dans l'archipel
du goulag en a parlé et quand on a édité
en 1960 à 1962 son premier livre une
journée d'ivan denissovitch qui était le
premier livre sur les camps il faut pas
oublier qu'il s'agissait d'une journée
dans un camp et d'une bonne journée mais
pas du système parce que il n'y a eu
aucun livre sur les stèles en dehors de
l'archipel
après une journée d'ivan denissovitch il
allait il faut pas sauter si vite parce
que en fait seul pays qui n'a pris donc
et quand il écrit une journée d'ivan
denissovitch il est créé en 1959 mais il
ne songe absolument pas la pub lille est
un écrivain souterrain qui est écrit
dans le plus grand secret c'est
seulement à la fin 1961 quand il y a le
22ème congrès du parti qui renouveau
départ de déstalinisation eolia un
discours de ce grand poète populaire qui
est rare d'obscurs qui appelle les
écrivains à dire la vérité demande aux
écrivains leur collaboration la
déstalinisation que soljenitsyne se
décide a révélé qu'il est un écrivain
c'est à ce moment là qu'il se décide à
faire parvenir à faire dos qui sont pros
son livre le plus montrable parce qu'il
en a écrit d'autres pour le premier
cercle il fait parvenir une journée
d'ivan denissovitch intrados ce qui est
rare de ski qui est candidat au comité
central s'est trouvé le chemin pour que
le livre arrive jusqu'à coup de chauffe
seul capable de prendre la décision de
le publier et le livre est publié 562
dans nos vies mire le rgi de fardeaux ce
qui est à ce moment là alors comment
et c'est là peut être la partie la plus
étonnante de ce livre commence lanka
licence la double vie d'alexandre
soljenitsyne qui devient tout d'un coup
un écrivain révélée est un écrivain
exposé en même temps exposés aux
manoeuvres de la police
exposée aux intrigues de l'union des
écrivains puisqu'un a publié une journée
d'ivan denissovitch mais qui en même
temps c'est que toute une partie de son
oeuvre est impubliables et qui continue
son oeuvre souterraine qui va donner
l'archipel du goulag qui va donner
précisément cherché n'élevons où il
raconte tout cela et le chêne et levez
haut vos gants bonnets c'est le récit de
la partie de la correspondance entre la
partie de l'écrivain public qui se bat
pour être publiées mais de l'écrivain
sauter l'un porteur des secrets donc il
sait qu'il ne peut pas être publié
mais la correspondance entre ces deux
parties doivent est très importante
parce que c'est l'oeuvre souterraine qui
donne à soljenitsyne la force morale de
déjouer les intrigues auxquels il est
exposé et lui donne en quelque sorte si
vous voulez le le moyen de triompher de
toutes les embûches
parce que finalement on ne publiera
qu'une journée d'ivan denissovitch on ne
publiera que les nouvelles comme la
maison de matriona l'inconnu de
chrétiens coptes offta on ne publiera
pas le pavillon des cancéreux qui
pourtant était une oeuvre publiables
simplement parce que là il ya les
limites du système des limites de la
censure et vous comprenez ce livre sa
force explosive
il la tient du fait que soljenitsyne en
quelque sorte inventé une stratégie
capable de briser la censure qui jusque
là avait absolument museler la
littérature soviétique et broyer les
écrivent
et je dois dire qu'une chose la plus
étonnante pour moi
qu'ils aient connu tarde aussi qu'il est
interviewé à paris en 65
c'est dedans le portrait de fardeaux ce
qui fera dossier était un grand poète
populaire
c'est un homme qui avait inventé le
personnage de faciliter au quine le
personnage du poète qu'on lui donne et
d'un soldat que tous les soldats de la
guerre de 2 41 45 connaissait cet homme
était comme je le dis a commis un
candidat au comité central
donc dans le sun il vous vous voyez le
passage de cet homme qui découvre une
journée de demain denissovitch comprend
tout de suite le talent de soljenitsyne
tout ce que ça représente mais qui en
même temps doit par une longue lutte
petit à petit se débattre avec le
système vient alors je maintenant je
posais les